calma sendo tranquila gostei do do vídeo da animação gostei acho que ia ser mais realista ia ser mais realista mas achei achei que me despertou também a curiosidade de ver as várias coisas que estariam a acontecer hum
Como é que me sinto?
Sinto-me ainda mais abstraída da cirurgia.
Sim, sim, sinto que durante estes minutinhos deu para desligar, não é?
Do que está a acontecer e estar assim, embranhada aqui na pequena experiência.
Portanto, sim, sinto que foi positivo.
Eu acho que não tenho nada a dizer.
Normalmente é uma coisa boa.
Correu tudo bem.
Acho que foi tudo bem.
As pessoas com quem encontrei, acho que foram todas muito atenciosas.
Acho que sem parecer aquela coisa falsa ou exagerada, porque às vezes...
Não, acho que foi tudo muito cordial e acho que foi tudo muito profissional e...
E educado e simpático e não tenho nada, aliás, não tenho nada, só o seja, não tenho nada de mal, mas tenho tudo bem a dizer.
Só se alentar, porque acho que sinto-me segura de estar aqui.
Às vezes parece que das experiências que eu tive, não só da minha parte, mas do acompanhamento que fiz a outros doentes, nomeadamente os meus pais,
Às vezes nós não sabermos se as pessoas estão a ser, no mínimo, profissionais, deixam-nos muito mais incertos.
Não é de saber, pronto, será que alguém está a olhar?
Será que alguém está a ver?
Será que tem esse aspecto?
Acho que é bom, é bom estar aqui.
E estar noutros sítios, em grande circunstância, estou satisfeita com a minha escolha.
Estou segura também.
Que não estaria melhor em outro sítio.